ah so obviously i said to you
i think i said to you at the beginning
of the month i'm going to try and do no
fat feb yeah good luck
fam
i was
i was even asked to see how that's going
i knew you would have forgotten
i was so like i psyched myself psyched
myself up for it this that and yeah i
was like
cool let's say i message you on the
monday cause i remember when it was
wanked on a tuesday
[Music]
because you needed to or because you
were just bored i don't i can't remember
it was such a long ago because it was
the beginning of the month i don't you
can't remember
but
it was one of those ones where obviously
the pnc just hit him as soon as i bust
man i was like what have i done i
couldn't make it 24 hours
i couldn't even make it 24 hours bro you
know
so when you were doing it did you know
you were breaking cards of course of
course i know i wasn't like
lost
no i knew i was breaking clear but i
still did it
i still loaded up the search engine
everything everything bro dread
everything nah but then then i lost it i
think another two weeks or maybe a week
and a half okay and then i did it again
and then i went again i was like yo this
is impossible fam oh this is actually
possible i actually want to try it again
but i need to be having
sex when i'm doing it because bro your
boy was having wet dreams i think i told
you i think i told her on here
when i tried it i don't oh yes yes yes
your boy had a wet dream
yes yes
i can't big man like you i'm gonna
believe big 30 year old man i believe it
world cup boxes merch fam and then no
it's horny because my dick was still
hard in my boxes so then so then i was
like [ __ ] this so i just had a wank
i'm done with this now i'm not playing
these challenges in games i went to a
message of don who said it was a good
idea because he was a patron in it i
want to message him like big man you
never said this was a possibility
wet dreams bro i had a wet dream i've
not had a wet dream since i was a you
same since i was an absolute young wet
dream i woke up like oh [ __ ] this
bashed one out straight away
and then got new boxers on and killed
please clean boxes on the kit
i was so angry bro no because when you
have a wet dream because that's
basically god forcing you to have one
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah he's like yeah
no fat what yeah there you go hold that
hold that and you think what was the
point
what have i accomplished i'd never i
rate you for making it two weeks after
that though because i've never felt
horniness liking
i've never felt
oh what was it
i'm pretty sure
i was thinking
about banging someone who's not paying
fam who's just in my general life like a
client or something i know what you mean
yeah you start you start romanticizing
fantasizing about everyone oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i've been there
i've been there and then you're like
this can't run yeah i've definitely been
there bro you start looking at people
differently
i never noticed that that's what it was
when i was a kid
i remember the day i had my first wank
in my life i only remember this was
because i was i was at my wit's end
i'll tell you a story
yeah i remember being i might have saw
the story before but i was at my wit's
end yeah because i was on holiday with
my family yeah
and i saw yes you saw titties on the
beach but they were all teased
in it was in uh
it was in spain spain okay and it was
just like the most
weathered tits that you've seen oh my
god and i but because it was titty
bro your boy i would have banged her she
was like 60 from 100 at that point when
i was 14 15 or however old i was i would
have banged her yeah i would have banged
her and i got home that night shaking
thinking i can't
keep doing this like i can't live like i
can't concentrate i can't see anything
yeah
i just need to [ __ ] something i need to
do something and then i thought i'm
gonna have to give this ranking thing
and go because i remembered i'd actually
tried it maybe a year before
nothing happened i was like this is
pointless what am i even doing had a man
like enjoy this this is terrible i was
very aware that i was touching myself do
you know what i mean
i was very aware that's what happened i
was thinking this is [ __ ] so then fast
forward a year on the holiday i was
thought i'm gonna have to try it again
because i literally can't focus i can't
do anything fam did it fapped and
literally the person clarity washed over
me like a baptism
i've never seen [ __ ] so clear
and i literally
i just remember saying like like
whispering because we're in a small
little like villa or whatever i remember
thinking thank god i was just like thank
god
thank god well there you go over with
yeah that's done i don't have to feel
like this anymore
little did i know like man said he got
to the hotel and he was shake
[Music]
[Laughter]
bro i couldn't see straight
i've never felt hormones like that's
hilarious i had my first rank and then
the relief of the pnc yeah was just like
oh
man literally bathed over me like holy
water jesus christ that's hilarious
thank god i remember one of my earliest
moments i had a um i had a wet dream
this was again back in my old old yard
me and my sister's share room our beds
were opposite each other
um
and this was back when your boy was
wearing the um you know them loose boxes
the kitchen towels kitchen towel boxes
with the button in the middle yeah yeah
back then i was wearing those obviously
i can't remember the actual dream in
itself but all i know is that i was i
remember i have a penetrating side on my
toes between tees but i felt you know i
felt the ocean and emotion
yeah you know yeah yeah i felt sad
i was feeling saturn and my hips was
deciding while i was sleeping that's all
i know and that's all i remember
lo and behold bro boycott that was not
there was not ever and i think
i think i woke up thinking what the
actual i think i think i woke up
thinking did i piss myself yeah yeah i
was so young i didn't realize i didn't
know how to differentiate the two you
know yeah and i was like damn what's
going on what do i do blah blah blah
but i was like
i i specifically remember
trying to get back to sleep to try and
continue the dream that's what i
remember now you're awkward because i i
never felt anything like it because
obviously i was obviously a virgin
and for some reason the dream
the dream allowed you to experience like
that you've never even felt i felt like
i was in a paranormal activity type
thing
because the dream
the way my tool fit through the thing
the way everything bro
everything
like say a [ __ ] porter guys whip your
tool out that wasn't just it just didn't
make sense it just didn't make sense bro
[Laughter]
bro it was nuts
it was nuts i've never felt anything
like it felt so real it felt like flesh
james
i felt like [ __ ] flesh but i never
felt any literally never felt any like
it cause i was a virgin been there bro
nuts that's hilarious
[Music]